hi I'm Mel and in this lecture we're
going to talk about the reasons why you
should recycle aluminum cans so we've
been talking about electricity and it's
related to that but let's start out with
talking about one of the reasons why we
do not recycle aluminum so aluminum is
not a rare element that's some thing we
need to establish if I look at all of
the the common elements that's in the
crust of the earth
number one is oxygen number two is
silicon number three is aluminum okay
seven and a half percent of everything
in the crust is aluminum now it's not
pure aluminum metal it's aluminum mixed
in with other elements to form minerals
point being we don't recycle aluminum
because aluminum itself is rare there's
other reason there's another reason why
so let's talk about how we actually get
aluminum metal and so what we're working
up towards is the steps to get from this
material which is called bauxite and
it's these red blogs that have aluminum
bearing minerals in there we're going to
work towards the step from this rock to
say an aluminum can like what is
required
okay so bauxite is a mixture of these
red blobs and from a distance bauxite
often has this reddish appearance and
bauxite forms wherever you had a lot of
precipitation for a long period of time
so what happens is all of the rains so
think of like a rain forest what rains
almost every day it reaches the soil
away and the only components that are
left over are these aluminum burying
compounds called bauxite so what we're
looking at here is a remnant of a
ancient soil that is left over from an
era where there's a lot of precipitation
so you might have an area that's
tropical today and there's lots of rain
and that's leaving behind the bauxite or
you might find a remnant of an ancient
box I'd soil from the geologic past
either way this red material that's left
behind after all of that precipitation
contains a lot of this mineral bauxite
so first thing they got to do is just
simply dig it up and so that's what
they're doing here you see all this red
box site in the foreground here and
bauxite mines are very red like
everything's red because this bauxite
mineral itself is red so here's one from
the from the air you can see the roads
are red the mine mining areas are red
here the buildings are red everything in
this in this photo is kind of a reddish
tint this is all bauxite that's being
mined now you can kind of see the where
there's runoff from a bauxite mine
because it it will also be red so this
was a river and it's filled with this
reddish muck here
that's bauxite runoff here's a here's a
place where there there was an overflow
of a river and you can see this reddish
material that went through here that's
again from a bauxite mine
there are some places in the world where
bauxite is being mined it gets into the
water so you see this reddish in this
waterway here that's from a nearby
bauxite mine in this town here you can
see all the red so this is a road that
leads to bauxite mines there's trucks
that go by here every day and some of
the material falls off and you can see
all that reddish stuff so bauxite you
know the mining process itself is you
just it's pretty simple you dig it out
of the ground but of course a lot of it
somehow
runs off into the environment so they
crush the bauxite into sand sized pieces
and then they usually haul it on a barge
so they're filling up these ships here
and here there here are some barges with
bauxite sitting in in the bay there here
you can see the little piles of red
bauxite here's a big ship that's full of
bauxite inside and they haul it off to a
smelter ok so here's a smelter and it's
built near near a waterway like a bay or
something because they're expecting
these shipments of bauxite
a smelter is a plant that is going to
take that red bauxite material and split
it apart so that we have aluminum metal
okay so we're going to go from from
bauxite grains to pure metal that's what
a smelter does and we're going to talk
about the stages here so here's a
smelter right there and here's what
they're doing in there so the problem is
bauxite itself is a mixture of things
and they want to purify it to this pier
to a compound al2o3 so there is other
stuff mixed in there and they want to
get rid of it they want pure al2o3 so
what they do is they take the bauxite
remember it's been crushed up now and
they subjected to heat and pressure and
water and sodium hydroxide which is kind
of like Drano so it's a strong base and
they cook it and what happens is all the
stuff that's not al2o3
gets dissolved away and here's an image
of a smelter and you can see all these
smokestacks which tells you that there's
probably some air pollution being
produced here and this process is one of
the things that that produces some of
the pollution in this process but at the
end of all that you have al2o3 which we
also call alumina okay now after that
chemical separation we have a the
biggest problem of all which is that
what we want is pure aluminum al we
don't want the oxygen in there but we
don't have that we have al 2o3 and it
turns out that the bond between the
oxygen and the aluminum is very strong
so from chemistry if we draw out what al
2o3 looks like here's our aluminum we've
got these double bonds here on the
oxygen and we have to break those bonds
and it turns out it's very difficult to
do so the way that it's done is they mix
in this chemical cryolite which is
sodium aluminum fluoride which is itself
a pretty nasty chemical and they mix it
in with this al2o3 and they put it in
this big vat and then they run a very
strong electrical current through it
what'll happen is as the current runs
through this mixture the pure aluminum
that essentially it breaks the those
bonds those double oxygen bonds and it
the pure aluminum metal sinks to the
bottom as a liquid and then they come in
they extract that liquid from the bottom
of the VAT so this is what it looks like
so you can see this glowing reddish
color here these are the electrodes so
the VAT is below the ground electricity
the current is coming down through these
electrodes going down into below the
ground here and they're running hundreds
of thousands of amps through this
mixture and what floats two against
sinks to the bottom is the aluminum
metal and this thing is like a vacuum
cleaner and it's sucking up the
aluminium metal off the bottom that's
what they're doing and so what they'll
do is they'll just go down the line here
you can see these things all the way
down to the end of this building they're
all doing this this takes a lot of
electricity so each one of these vats
that you see here has a set of
electrodes
each of which is going through thousands
of amps so from what we talked about
before it's going through each one of
the each one of these is hundreds of
thousands of watts so this is another
picture what that looks like so here's
their aluminum sucker upper and here's
all that the VATS so it requires so much
electricity to do this that often in the
in the entrance of an aluminum smelter
you'll you'll see this huge network of
incoming power lines and sometimes they
need so much electricity that they
actually have their own power plant so
here is a smelter that's these are long
gate buildings in the background that's
the smelter and then this is a cold fire
power plant you can see there's the coal
piled up right there so this this
aluminum smelter needs so much
electricity that they actually have
their own coal-fired power plant
here's one in Eastern Washington that
has its own dam so there's the
smelter you see the elongate buildings
there's the hydroelectric dam so so
water is going through a turbine which
turns magnets which generates
electricity and so that's how they get
enough power to run the smelter so if we
add up the electricity that it would
take to develop a brand new aluminum can
from that bauxite mineral it turns out
it takes about 350 watt hours of energy
to make one aluminum can from scratch if
you instead recycle a can all they have
to do is melt it down they don't have to
split the aluminum oxygen bonds and it
takes about 5% of that so we can do some
math with this so it takes 350 watt
hours to make one aluminum can we could
ask questions like this so how much coal
would you need to make 12 cans all right
so we have a 12 pack of aluminum cans of
soda cans whatever and we want to know
how much coal did we have to burn to do
that so from last time these are the
we're going to use the same numbers as
last time you get your power and
kilowatt hours they're from kilowatt
hours you multiply that by two point two
for the pounds of coal or times a
thousand for the leaders of co2 etc all
the things that we did before so my
energy is 350 watt hours times I get 12
of them so I just take 350 times 12 and
get 4200 watt hours and to convert
that's kilowatt hours I divide by a
thousand and I get 4.2 kWh okay so
that's how much energy it takes to make
a 12-pack how much coal is that so let's
say I ask for coal in pounds
then all I have to do is take this 4.2
and multiply 2.2 pounds per
kilowatt-hour
and four point two times two point two
is nine point two four okay so it's
helped us nine point two four pounds of
coal to make a 12-pack of cans how much
co2 is that so I go back to my kilowatt
hours and multiply by a thousand and I
get four point two kilowatt hours times
a thousand liters for every kilowatt
hour gives me 4200 liters of co2 okay so
that's what's required to make our cans
12-pack of cans so if I throw them away
then I've got to expend this much you'll
burn this much coal and produce this
much co2 to make another twelve but if I
recycle them they can just melt them
down and make new ones and it only takes
about 5% of that there's another set of
problems we can do we could say
something like this let's let's imagine
that I I've got a computer a little
laptop that uses 14 watts okay so
imagine pretty you know a fairly modern
small laptop and I want to know if I
took those twelve cans and I just threw
them away instead of recycling them I'm
throwing away energy right throwing away
the electricity that it would take
because I got to make 12 new cans how
long could I run a computer with that
electricity that I just threw away by
tossing those cans right so how long
could I run a computer on the
electricity it takes to make 12 new cans
okay so again the idea is if I throw a
lovely weekend away
I must not recycle it I got expend a
bunch of energy to make a new one so if
I had a 14 watt computer how long could
I use that computer how long could I run
it on 12 cans worth of energy so the
formula I'm going to use to figure this
out is the same one we've done before
energy is power times time okay so
what's my energy my energy is how much
energy it took to make 12 cans we just
solve that we said it was 4.2 kilowatt
hours and the power is 14 watts times
time we don't know what time is that's
what we're solving for so this is an
algebra problem where we're just going
to divide both sides and isolate time
but there's one step we have to do and
that is this we we did a conversion to
get watt hours to kilowatt hours so what
we have to do is get rid of that K
before we can do the math because we got
one hour
we got watts over here we're gonna have
times that in hours as an answer we got
to get rid of this K so I'm gonna go
back to what we had before this 4200
right here and I'm gonna put that in I'm
just kidding I'm just going backwards
multiple getting rid of stead of
dividing by a thousand multiplying a
thousand to get rid of the K just I'm
gonna write this out watt hours equals
14 watts times time
okay so now I'm going to divide both
sides by 14 Lots so I take 4200 divided
by 14 and I get 300 hours so so that
means I could turn that computer on and
leave it on continuously for 300 hours
on the electricity would take to make 12
new cans so we could even let's divide
that by 24 and that's 12 and a half days
so the point being that when we don't
recycle in the aluminum can we're
essentially throwing late electricity
that could be used for something else
okay so to recap the process if you mine
about 4 tons of bauxite the mineral and
then you run it through that chemical
digestion process you get about 2 tons
of alumina which is al2o3
you don't want al2o3 you want pure
aluminum and you run it through that
second process that that's the part that
takes all of the electricity and you get
one ton of actual aluminum metal so
because it takes a lot of electricity to
make cans
we'd like to recycle as many as possible
it turns out as a country we're really
bad at doing this so here's an old old
graph that was published in 2002 and it
looks at how how many says thousands of
tons per year of lunar cans were thrown
away in the United States right so there
weren't really too many aluminum cans
before 1970 so the graph kind of starts
in 1970 and what we see is that as time
has gone on and as aluminum cans became
more and more popular we just threw more
and more of them away right so they they
calculated in this in again this is
where the year 2001 so in 1972 2001 that
16mm
tons of aluminum was just simply thrown
away over that time period and if you
look at a more modern records we really
have not gotten any better so here's I
from 96 to 2015 we're looking at how how
well we have recycled aluminum and so
there's a there's the blue line in a red
line for industry and consumers but the
point is is here's a 50% mark right so
we are recycling a little bit better
than half of the cans and then you can
see it dips back down again and then it
gets better so the red line you can
imagine that's us as consumers and it's
hovering around the 50% mark so in other
words we pretty much throw away about
half of our aluminum cans and when I
teach this cost face to face usually in
a college classroom I will go over to
the garbage can at this point and I'll
open it and I guarantee there are
aluminum cans in the trash and right
next to the trash was usually a
recycling bin so in other words it's not
even it doesn't even require any effort
to do the recycling people simply just
don't care back to that 2002 paper they
were they were looking at again they're
calculating how many aluminum cans were
wasted from 1972 in this case to 2000 so
there's a couple interesting numbers
here one is how much electricity
did we throw away it says exactly half
of all US homes for one year so in other
words we could power half of it all the
homes in the United States for a year on
the electricity that we threw away
essentially from aluminum cans alone or
you can do equivalent that's equivalent
is fifteen thousand seven hundred ninety
six million gallons of gasoline are 342
million barrels of oil that's how much
an energy equivalent that we threw away
during that time period so a couple more
statistics every six months we throw
away enough aluminum to rebuild the
world supply of commercial
planes so airplanes are made of aluminum
because aluminum is very light so every
six months we could just replace all the
commercial airlines and airplanes in the
world based on the amount of cans that
we throw away the electricity that we
could save each year by recycling the
throwing away cans would would be enough
electricity to power three million US
homes so three million houses we could
power each year just on the cans or
chucking so when we make new cans
remember it takes 350 watt hours per can
plus you've got the bauxite mining and
all the runoff from that you've got the
air pollution from the chemical
digestion process all the greenhouse
gases that we're making all those things
count so why do we recycle cans not
because aluminum is rare because it's
not because it takes so much electricity
to make it can that's why